The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
So I decided to make today's
lecture the one on linear
programming and duality,
which I'd planned for Friday,
and give myself two more
days to learn about ill-posed
and inverse problems, and
then come back to that Friday,
so that -- we've studied
the limits in those problems
of alpha going to infinity or
0, but the scientific question
when there's noise in the
system is finite alpha,
and I want to learn more about
applications and examples.
Can I also say I'm very happy to
have had volunteers for Monday
and Wednesday of
next week to present,
and if a couple of
people might maybe
volunteer for Friday, to share
Friday, I'll be very grateful.
So you could see me after
class, put a hand up now,
send me an email -- all
those would be very good.
And again, I would
be thinking --
since it's just next
week I'm talking about --
that it would be essentially a
report on your Project One that
you would use the
overhead projector maybe,
if that's preferable.
OK.
So I think you'll
like this topic.
It's kind of specific but widely
used -- linear programming --
used in business to maximize
profits, to minimize costs.
And linear means that the
cost function is linear.
That's an inner product -- c*x.
c is a row vector, x
is a column vector,
so that I'm following the
conventions of this subject
here to take these
different shapes,
so let me indicate
what the shapes are.
But the inputs are -- the data
of the problem are -- c and A,
an m by n matrix, and b.
So A is m by n, b is m by
1 -- right-hand side --
and c is 1 by n.
And then the unknown -- this is
the thing that we're to find --
it's a column vector, n by 1.
OK.
And the point is
there are constraints
and those are linear too.
So it's rather unusual to
have a linear cost function.
Right?
Because when you maximize or
minimize some linear function,
well, the thing is just going
up or it's going down --
or in higher dimensions the
same -- and if it's going down,
then the minimum is going
to be at the right-hand end.
Or if it's going up, the minimum
will be at the left-hand end.
And if I'm in more
variables, this idea
will still be true that
the minimum or maximum
will happen at the edges, at
the ends of the allowed region.
And this allowed region,
called the feasible set --
so let me give the name to this
-- these are the allowed x's.
These are the constraints.
And that set is called the
feasible set, feasible meaning
doable.
So those constraints
include inequalities,
because we want finite
intervals, finite regions in n
dimensions.
And I drew a sort
of quick picture
so that you have
a model of this.
So this is a picture with
n equals 3 -- 3 dimensions,
and so the constraints
x greater or equal 0,
x_1 greater or equal 0,
x_2 greater or equal 0,
x_3 greater or equal 0 --
that's what x greater or equal 0
means.
It means all components.
So we're in the quadrant right?
We're in a quarter -- 1/8
sorry -- we're in an octant --
1/8 of three-dimensional
space, the positive octant.
And then if I draw maybe just
one, just put in one equation,
one plane, would cut off
a piece of that octant,
so that A*x greater or equal
b, depending on the signs,
but the feasible set could
well be the tetrahedron,
the little piece of the octant
that's cut out by this plane.
Or if our constraint
was an equality,
the feasible set
would be the triangle.
So A*x equal to b would
lead to the triangle,
and A*x greater or equal b, if
we pick the signs correctly,
would be the pyramid, would
include also this corner,
because there'd be some volume.
OK.
So the feasible set
is a polyhedron.
It's like a polygon, only
up into n dimensions,
so we use the word polyhedron.
And it's got corners, and the
whole point of the linear cost,
the linear objective
function c*x --
so this is just c_1*x_1 plus...
plus c_n*x_n; that's
what that means.
If I take derivatives,
I get constants.
I don't set derivatives to
0 in this type of problem.
I look at the endpoints,
at the corners.
And that's where the minimum
and maximum will occur.
So it's just a question of
finding the right corner.
That's the problem: how to
find the winning corner.
It's an interesting competition
between two quite different
approaches: the famous approach
-- so let me write these two.
The simplex method is the
best established, best known
approach for solving
these problems.
What's the idea of
the simplex method?
The simplex method
finds a corner.
A corner is a case where we
have some equality signs.
A corner is the edge, the limit
where maybe this one still
has x_1 positive but
it's down in this plane
so it has maybe x_3
is 0 for this guy.
So that corner has x_3 equals
0 and it also lies right
on the plane, so it
has A*x equal to b.
This corner -- well, I guess
that corner has all these guys
equal 0: x_1 equals 0, x_2
equals 0, x_3 equals 0,
but A*x -- inequality's
holding here for this corner
that's hiding behind the face.
Anyway, corners are points
where some of the constraints
are tight or active
and others are not.
Well, you might say:
just check them all,
but the trouble is there
are lots of corners.
If we're in n dimensions and
we have m constraint equations,
then the number of corners
goes up exponentially.
So no way to check all of them.
So the simplex method
had a better idea.
The simplex method
found one of them --
and already that's a little
bit of a job, to find a corner,
but finds one.
And then what the
simplex method does,
it stays entirely, it
moves along the edges.
So from here, it
will look to see in
which direction would the
cost go down, because we're
trying to minimize the cost.
So it would check
these directions.
Each of those directions
we're releasing one equality.
We're allowing one equality
to be an inequality,
and that moves us along.
So the simplex
method has two steps.
It checks each of
these directions
to find out which way will
the cost drop fastest.
It chooses the direction in
which the cost -- the gradient,
the component of the
gradient, you could say,
along that edge is the biggest,
or maybe the most negative.
And then, once it decides
which way to go, it goes --
maybe it takes this direction
-- it goes, goes, goes, goes,
goes until it hits
another corner.
So that's the end
of the simplex step,
when it reaches another corner.
That completes one simplex step.
Then, from this corner, it
will look the three ways
it could go here.
Well, it's not going to
pick this way, we know,
because in this direction
the cost was decreasing
or we wouldn't have taken it.
We wouldn't have
taken that direction
except that the cost went down.
So if we came back,
the cost would go up.
No good.
So going down would be
one of these two ways.
Maybe it goes down
in this direction,
so we decide on that direction.
We follow it until
we hit a new corner,
and eventually we're going
to get to the winning corner
because there are only a
finite number of corners.
And how will we know
it's the winning corner?
Well, we'll know that
corner is a winner
if, in every direction,
the cost goes up.
If the cost goes up
in all directions,
along all the edges
out of that corner,
then that corner has won.
It's the minimum.
I'm using linearity here -- the
fact that you know everything
by traveling along, by
looking along those edges.
So the simplex method
is a big success.
Because in reality,
in practice, it
turns out that the
number of edges
that you have to travel
to get to the winner
doesn't grow exponentially.
I mean in principle it could.
People have dreamt up really
desperate examples in which
following the simplex method
you could take a long time,
but on average you don't,
and in practice you don't.
So it's a very
good method and was
totally the method of choice.
But a competitor has arrived.
And that competitor goes under
the name of interior point
method, and you can
guess what that method is
doing quite different,
totally different system.
That method is inside
the feasible set.
It finds a point somewhere
near the middle maybe.
And then it does normal,
gradient-type approach
from your point.
It figures out
which way to move.
It moves, but it
doesn't go outside.
It doesn't even reach the
boundary of the feasible
set, because if you reach the
boundary of the feasible set,
you're out of the interior
and the method is not
going to operate.
Well, that crudest method
would be follow the gradient,
but we know from
several situations
that gradient descent
can be less than optimal.
So this is more subtle.
Well, Newton's method
actually -- I'll explain.
So this is actually the
content of my lecture --
this interior point method.
And let me just
mention a few names.
People thought of interior
point methods long ago,
but a big splash
came when Karmarkar
proposed an interior
point method
and proved that it converged
faster than simplex
method in some problems.
Well, he said all
problems, actually.
His advertising of the
message was pretty generous.
The sort of claim
that was around
was, you know, ten times as
fast as the simplex method,
generally, and it was on the
front page of the New York
Times, and I remember going
to a lecture in Boston
with lights, TV lights
on and everything.
Well, maybe his exact method
now isn't so much used,
but you have to give him credit
for stirring up the whole world
of optimization because the
result of Karmarkar's method --
and there were others -- and
I'll say barrier methods,
and that's what
I'll try to explain.
He stirred up the whole
world so that the experts
in optimization began looking
again at interior point
methods, seeing that
they did have some merit,
improving them.
And now for, I would
say particularly
for large, sparse problems,
these are a way to go.
These are preferred now.
So this is the normal situation
in scientific computing:
that any method
that's good, it's
still not good for everything.
It's got a range of problems
where it's successful
and a range of problems
where some competitor wins.
So that's the situation now.
These are methods.
This is certainly
not out of date,
and I'm sure it's
the method of choice
and it's carefully coded
and well understood,
but these are quite effective.
OK.
So my job then is
to say something
about these interior
point methods.
And the beauty of these
is that the primal --
this is called the
primal problem.
Primal problem.
And often you write
a P for primal.
It means the given problem.
And over here is
the dual problem.
So you put a D, dual problem.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
It involves the same
data: the same b,
the same A, and the same
c, but a new variable y.
And [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
is really
the Lagrange multiplier
in the original problem
for the constraints.
So I won't go at the dual
problem exactly that way.
I'm going to ask you just
to consider this problem
and show you the
relation between the two.
So what I want to say is
that these two problems --
the primal and the dual, which
use the same data A, b, c,
are intimately related, and sort
of solving one solves the other
one.
Actually is this it?
That applies to
the simplex method.
When the simplex method
finds the best corner,
we could read off the
Lagrange multipliers,
we could read off y.
We could read off the optimal y.
So my picture was
in the primal case,
but there's a dual
picture in the dual case.
OK.
So we have a minimum problem
and a maximum problem,
and I'm using this word duality.
So what I want to
do is tell you how
do we recognize the winning
corner in the primal problem,
and it's beautiful.
So at the best --
so the optimal x,
let me call it x
star and y star,
have min over there
equal the max here.
Min of all the c*x's,
which is c x star,
equal to a maximum over all of
the y's of the y*b's, which is
y star b.
So these are equal
at the winner.
That's the essence
of this duality.
Duality is about two problems
that use the same data
but they look quite different.
You know, they're using
the data in different ways.
The cost function there showed
up in the constraint here.
The constraint b there showed
up in the cost function here.
And even A got flipped, because
if I use my usual column vector
notation -- if I just
transpose this --
this would be A transpose y
transpose less or equal to c
transpose.
If I wanted to stay with column
vectors y transpose and c
transpose, then it would
be the transpose of A
that would appear.
So I'll just put transpose
with two exclamation marks.
That's typical.
And you often see
the word adjoint.
So there are methods in
differential equations,
in optimization,
called adjoint methods.
Adjoint is just, really,
another word for transpose.
It's a word that applies in
differential equations as well
as matrices, so it's kind of
a better word, you could say,
where transpose we
usually apply to matrices,
but totally the same
idea, identical idea.
OK.
So the wonderful thing is
that at the moment of success,
at the moment of
optimality, these are equal.
A minimum equals a maximum.
And that's one way to recognize
that you've succeeded,
and that's one way to
measure how far you have
to go, with the duality gap.
So the duality gap
would be the difference.
If you had a particular
y that wasn't the winner,
a particular x that
wasn't the winner,
the duality gap would be the
difference between c*x and y*b.
And what I'm saying is that when
that duality gap narrows to 0,
you've got it.
When this narrows to 0, you've
brought c*x down as far as you
could, you've raised y*b
up as far as you could.
And if you did it right, if
you've got to the optimum,
then the duality gap
disappeared -- became 0.
So that's a measure
of am I at the answer,
am I close, you know, if we're
going to do an iterative method
as I'm planning.
So that's the point, of course.
These interior point
methods will be iterative.
We step, we never
actually allow them
to get to the absolute corner
until maybe at the last minute.
So here, let me draw a
picture of how interior point
methods might work.
So here is the feasible set
-- some kind of a polyhedron,
whatever.
So think of that as a kind of
a diamond, a twenty-four carat
diamond.
OK?
And start at a point inside.
And somehow find the gradient,
decide which way to move,
dot dot dot dot.
And there'll be
some barrier here
which is going to prevent
us from reaching it,
so we'll stop.
So that will be one
step, and from here we
will do the same
thing, whatever it is.
It'll be Newton's
method, actually.
You'll see.
It's just Newton's method.
The most fundamental way to
solve non-linear equations
is Newton's method.
And it'll take
another direction.
Again it'll stop, and the
thing will follow some path.
And then maybe at this point
the duality gap is very small.
We'll realize that
this is the winner.
So we could, at the last minute,
say: OK, jump to the winner.
But it's this path
through the interior
that we're really interested in.
OK, so I'm giving a sort
of general picture of it.
And now I'm ready
to do two things.
One is the nice
little bit of algebra
that says that this duality gap
is always greater or equal 0.
OK.
So that's called weak duality.
Weak duality, which is easy to
prove, says that, always, c*x,
for any feasible x, is greater
or equal to y*b for any
feasible y.
So any x and y that
satisfy the constraints.
I should say satisfying
the constraints.
So weak duality I'll
now prove in one second.
And the point is that, as
I push to bring c*x down --
minimize -- as I push to
move y*b up -- maximize --
they will meet, at the winner.
OK, now how do I prove
c*x greater or equal y*b?
Let me try to prove that.
Proof.
OK, so look at y*b.
OK.
Now, so I know something
about the constraints.
A*x is greater or equal to b.
So this b -- I want to say that
this is less or equal to y*A*x.
Now am I allowed to say that?
First of all, y is
feasible; x is feasible.
So they satisfy.
Feasible means that
these are satisfied
and these are satisfied.
OK.
And do you see that
that's really all right?
Well you might say no problem.
A*x is greater or b.
It's obvious.
But I have actually used one
more point here, haven't I?
If I have an inequality,
then I'm multiplying it by y,
and it didn't change the
direction of the inequality
sign, and that was because
y is greater or equal 0.
That's where that paid off.
So this used the fact that --
this came from the fact that y
was greater or equal 0 and
A*x was greater or equal b.
Those two facts meant that I
could multiply and preserve
the inequality sign.
And now I'm going to
go to the next step:
y*A is less or equal
c, and there is x.
OK, so you see that I
finally got what I want:
y*b less or equal to c*x.
But what went into that step?
Well, looking here, I had
y*A less or equal to c,
and I also had x greater or
equal 0 by the feasibility
of x.
So that inequality I
was allowed to multiply
by x because x is not negative.
If x had been minus 1,
then when you -- right,
if I have an inequality
like 4 less or equal 7,
if I multiply by minus 1,
I get minus 4 and minus 7,
and the inequality switches:
minus 7 is below minus 4.
But that's not what's
happening here,
because the x is not negative.
So this is not what's
happening, and I'm OK.
So the conclusion was
exactly what I wanted --
that y*b was less
or equal to c*x.
And you see how perfectly
it used the four inequality
constraints.
OK.
So that's the weak duality
where the proof is easy.
Just use what's given.
The duality, without
the word weak,
is the fact that at the
optimum, the gap is 0,
and actually we can see --
that will tell us a lot.
That will tell us a lot.
When could this gap be 0?
So at the optimum, y star,
equality is holding throughout.
So if equality is
holding, how can that be?
How can I take these --
of course the inequality,
the x star and y
star are feasible.
So if I just put stars
on all these things,
then I would have -- everything
would still be totally true.
But when I put stars on them --
so I'm picking the optimal guys
-- then equality is holding.
I still have these inequalities,
so what I want to find
is the optimality conditions.
How are they related?
If I have y greater or equal
0 and A*x greater or equal b
and I multiply, how
could I get equality?
Right?
For example, if I have 3 greater
than 0 and 5 greater than 2,
if I multiply those, I get
15 greater than 0, I guess,
and that's far from
equality, right?
So how could equality happen?
Well, the only way is if one or
the other of these, if equality
holds in one or the
other, then I would be OK.
Yes, do you see that?
If equality held -- these
are vector inequalities,
so I'm going really
component by component.
Let me write down
the my conclusion
and then you'll see what I mean.
So these are called the
Kuhn-Tucker conditions.
You've seen their names before.
And they're also called
-- well, long words --
complementary slackness.
I'm using words that, if you
haven't seen the subject,
you think OK, who
needs the long words.
But the idea of
slack variable --
slack is the difference in the
-- the slack is c minus y*A,
or over here the
slack is A*x minus b.
These are the slack variables.
w, let's say, is A*x minus b.
And of course it's
greater or equal 0;
that's the nice thing
about slack variables.
You know, you've fixed it
so it's greater or equal 0.
Here, the slack variable s,
for slack, would be what?
c minus y*A, greater or equal 0.
And there's no
slack when s is 0.
OK, so that's where the
word slackness comes in.
Slack is just the amount
of give in the inequality.
So what's the point here?
I was looking at this
guy, and the only way
that I could have equality here,
when I have inequalities there,
is for each component, I'm
going to have to have equality.
And how can I have
equality on a component?
Well, I would have it
for example, if y was 0.
Then when I multiply,
I have equality.
Right?
OK.
Or I could have equality
if I had -- let's see,
so this is what I want to say.
So I want to say either
y_i is 0 or (A*x)_i is b_i.
Equality holds in one or
other of the two inequalities,
because then, if I multiply
them together, I have equality.
Right?
You see that.
If one of those holds, say
this one holds, if y_i i is 0,
then I certainly can
multiply the inequality by y
and I get 0 equals 0.
Or, if A*x is exactly b, then
multiplying by y won't change.
OK.
So this is the complementary
slackness, one or the other,
that has to hold
to get equality.
Now what about this guy?
Equality, same idea here.
I got the inequality by
multiplying these together.
When will I get equality?
Only if either x_j is 0 or the
j-th component of y*A equals
the j-th component of c.
Again, the same reasoning: that
when I multiply two things,
if I get an equality
out of two inequalities,
then one of those two at
least must have been actually
an equals; otherwise
I'd still have a gap.
OK, so this is pretty important.
These are the conditions
-- these are our equations.
That tells us when we've won.
So this actually
holds for the winners.
It doesn't hold for all the
other guys, but at the winner,
because things are
equal here, they
had to be equal at every
step, and therefore
the Kuhn-Tucker conditions
had hold at the winner.
So they hold at this winning
corner when we find it.
So the simplex method
chases corners, finally
gets to a corner,
and it would know
it had got there
by the fact that it
couldn't decrease any more.
And if you look at
the algebra, you
would see that that tells you
that the Kuhn-Tucker conditions
are satisfied.
OK, so the only proof I
gave was the weak proof,
that c*x is greater or equal
to y*b because that's the nice
one.
I've proved that for
equality we'd need these.
OK, now I guess I'm
ready for the method.
I'm ready for the interior
point barrier method
that tells me how to compute.
OK, so I'm at an interior point.
What do I do?
OK, so here's the method;
here's the barrier --
I'll call it a log barrier.
I'll solve the problem
of minimizing c*x.
I won't solve the exact problem.
I'm going to minimize
c*x minus, I think,
some little number
times a barrier,
which is going to be a sum
of the logarithms of the x's.
This alpha is going to
be a little bit positive.
I'll take it smaller and smaller
because this part is really --
it's that that I really
want to minimize.
Right?
That's the original problem.
This is the cost.
I'm adding something to the
cost but I'd better just
be sure that I've chosen
the sign of alpha correctly.
By the way, this
is discussed now
in the latest version
of my Linear Algebra
and its Applications
textbook, the fourth edition.
Editions one to three
of that book and others
have described the
simplex method,
and now it was just natural
to include the interior point
barrier method.
OK, so why do I
call this a barrier?
Because if x_i gets to
0, the log blows up.
The log blows down
I should say --
blows down to minus infinity.
I'm multiplying by minus
alpha, so I get positive.
The combination blows up.
It couldn't be the
minimum, so you see,
the minimum is never going
to make it to x equals 0,
because at x equals 0, the thing
I have here is plus infinity.
So now, I'm just going
to use gradient method.
I'm going to solve this
problem with the constraints,
of course, with the constraints,
and set derivatives to 0.
Now I have -- you know,
it's not linear anymore --
the winner is not
at a corner anymore.
It's somewhere in the middle.
Calculus operates.
I can set derivative to 0.
OK, so I want to do that.
And of course, I'm still
inside this feasible set,
so let me see if I can
put down the equations
and the constraints.
OK, so I still have
the constraints.
Now, forgive me, but I've
made a change to A*x equals b.
I could have started with
that as the constraint.
I've made that change
to A*x equals b.
How have I done such a thing?
I'm given the problem with
A*x greater or equal b,
but I'm also given the slack
variable w greater or equal 0.
So I just -- it's just a little
trick that's not worth --
you could just take my word
for it, a little trick.
My new variable is
the x's and the w's.
m plus n variables: the
n x's and the m w's.
And now, put that together --
so can I just maybe do this over
in the corner here?
Before I start on this, I
changed to a new variable that
that'll be x's and w's.
And that will be greater
or equal 0, right?
Because the x was always
greater or equal 0,
and the slack says A*x greater
or equal b is turned into slack
greater or equal 0.
And now that multiplies
A, minus I to give b,
because A*x minus the
slack variable is b,
which says that A*x minus b
is the slack variable w --
bring that over and that over
-- and that's what we said was
greater or equal 0.
Do you see that I've
changed to an equation
by introducing more variables?
Putting the x's and the slacks
all together in a big variable
that I'm now going to call x.
So this is now the sum of --
there's are m plus n of these
x's now, because -- this is the
new x and this is the new A.
You might say: why didn't I just
start with equality constraint?
And I certainly could have done.
But just to see that
inequalities have their place
too, and to see that we can
get between one and the other.
OK, so now this is the problem
with equality constraint.
So my new constraints are A*x
equals b and x greater or equal
0.
That's the primal constraint.
And what's the dual constraint?
So the dual constraint
is y greater or equals 0.
Right?
And, OK I have to get this right
because we're right at the end.
And the slack, let me
just write the slack one.
The slack one -- s is the slack.
This is s.
I'm going to transpose so that
I have consistently column
vectors.
So that, when I transpose, it
says that A transpose y plus s
is c.
Right?
I put that over there
with the s and transpose
to get column vectors.
I like to have column vectors.
OK, so those are the
constraints, but now,
what's the derivative
equals 0 equation?
Derivative equals 0 is the
derivative of this equals 0.
So what does that say?
That says that if I set
the derivative as 0,
that says that c_i
-- x, remember, is --
well x has got all
these components.
c_i is alpha and the derivative
of log x_i, of course,
is 1 over x_i.
So that's the equation
for derivative equals 0.
So this is what I'm solving.
OK.
Equality is here,
equality is here,
equality is here, but nonlinear.
This is of course nonlinear.
So Newton's method
just says linearize.
Newton's method is just
linearize at the point,
and that gives you
the direction to move.
And you move that direction
because you've linearized.
As you move, you're wandering
a little away from precision,
from perfection, but if you
don't take too big a step,
Newton is safe.
Maybe, since this is a course
in scientific computing,
I should've written on the
very first day in big letters
Newton, because that idea
of following the gradient
is the central method of
solving non-linear equations.
And then on the board
beneath, I would
have written in big
letters "carefully,"
because the derivative
is a local thing.
And if you follow the
derivative a long distance,
follow the derivative here
a long distance out to here,
who knows what -- you've lost
the safety of Newton's method.
So Newton's method
always comes in reality
with some kind of a trust
region, some region where
you can rely on the
derivative being
a reasonable approximation of
the way the function is moving.
OK, so we do that here too.
OK.
Maybe I won't write
out in full notation --
what does Newton's
method do, actually?
So Newton's method, we're
at a particular x, y, s,
and we've got to move.
So the unknowns are ---
the components of x,
the components of y,
and the components of s.
So Newton's method takes
steps: a delta x, a delta y,
and a delta s, computes
what those should be,
and then that gives
the direction,
and if you take them exactly,
that's the full Newton
step, which you would be very
happy to do because that gives
terrific convergence, but
if it's too big a step,
then you have to cut back.
So the equations for
these are what you need,
so there'll be an A
delta x will be 0.
Because b isn't changing.
There will be an A transpose
delta y; A transposed delta y
plus delta s will be 0
because the c isn't changing.
And then we'll get
an equation out
of this, which is a really
significant one that maybe
time is running out on and I'm
not going to do justice to.
But that's the nonlinear
term, where, you see,
if I keep A delta x zero, then
my new x is exactly feasible
right?
If I'm at an A*x equals b
and I move it by a delta x
that's in the null space,
then I still have --
all I'm saying is that when I
take that step I will have A x
plus delta x still equal to b.
Good.
Constraints still satisfied.
When I take this step, since
that's linear, the constraint,
when I add on the delta y
and the delta s and the 0,
I still have -- my new
point still satisfies that
constraint.
But this is of course
not exactly satisfied.
If I had the solution
to this, I'd be done.
That's my problem.
Anyway, so it's not
exactly satisfied.
Newton would tell you
a linearization of it,
and you would move in that
gradient direction to try
to make the thing -- to
try to make equality hold,
because our current x doesn't
have equality holding.
And of course the c is
A transpose y plus s.
So that equation -- you
see what's going on here?
This is A transpose y plus s,
and the x is multiplying those,
so there's a product there.
And when I take the derivative,
it's a product rule,
I get two terms.
Anyway, I get a third
equation from here
that connects delta x,
delta y, and delta s.
I take that step and that's
my interior point method.
That's my Newton step.
So maybe I just end by
reporting the results,
so I'll end with
just two comments.
First is, is the
method any good?
And of course you
only know by trying.
And the answer is
yeah, in -- typically,
you get the duality gap down
below 10 to the minus 8,
which is usually
very satisfactory,
in 20 to 80 steps.
You can never prove a
statement like that,
because you can always
create some awful example,
but this is the typical
performance of the method.
Which is pretty good,
regardless of m and n.
That's what's wonderful --
that the number of steps
doesn't increase with
the size of the problem.
Of course, the cost
per step does increase
with the size of the problem.
OK so that's the
results, and that's
why the method is popular.
And now I just wanted
to not leave duality,
which is such a key
idea, without going back
to our much more familiar
problem of quadratics, where
there are quadratic terms.
And the best model you
remember was projection.
You remember that we had a
vector b and we have the line,
the null space of A. No, this
was the column space of A.
This was all A*x's.
And perpendicular to it was
the null space of A transpose.
All A transpose
y's that equaled 0.
Do you remember this?
This was the model problem
for understanding the --
so that the projection of
this solved one problem.
The projection in the other
direction -- we called that P.
This was the projection P
equal A times the best x.
The projection in the
opposite direction
found the e, the error,
but it was the solution
to the dual problem.
And now I want to say where
was duality in this picture?
Well, duality was -- let me
call it e hat, the winning,
the projection, the
right guy over here.
Or maybe y hat.
OK, where was duality?
Duality came, in this
case, in the fact
that it was Pythagoras.
Duality in this simple,
beautiful problem
was simply the fact that p
squared, this winner squared,
plus e squared was b squared.
The winners were the
orthogonal projections.
And now where is weak duality?
It's the last second
of the lecture.
Weak duality says take
something that's allowed,
like that, and take something
that's allowed here, like that.
Those are not the winners.
Those don't deserve
stars or hats.
They're not the winners.
And compute that squared
plus that squared.
So this is any A*x.
So any A*x squared and any y --
let's call that y -- squared.
And what is the inequality
that is satisfied by any A*x,
like the wrong one here, and
any y, like the wrong one there,
will satisfy?
Pythagoras won't be quite right.
It'll be A*x squared
plus y squared.
What do we know about the
sum of those two squares?
It's greater than or
equal to b squared.
The only way we get
this thing split
into two orthogonal parts whose
squares add up to b squared
is right triangle.
If I replace this by something
longer and I replace this --
I should take that error really.
e is really b minus the A*x.
That's what I should
be putting here.
This thing should be
b minus A*x squared.
Anyway, the duality
is in the fact
of getting an equal sign
there and weak duality
is the easy inequality
that no matter what you do,
you get greater than or equal.
So the duality gap is
somehow the gap there,
and the whole subject
of optimization
is to bring that gap to 0.
So this is the gap in
quadratic problems,
of which this is a neat
model, and this was
all about linear programming.
And duality is present for both.
OK, so Friday is the promised
lecture on ill-posed problems.
And meanwhile, if two
people are willing to put up
a hand now or email me
later and say: sure,
I'll take my turn Friday of next
week, that would be terrific.
OK.
Thanks.
I see one hand.
OK.